.
>>> LEADING FIGURES ON THE FAR
RIGHT HAVE BEEN SOUNDING THE
ALARM ON AFGHANISTAN EVACUEES
ALL WEEK.
THE REFUGEES ARE COMING.
>> PEOPLE BEING BROUGHT IN HERE,
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
PERCENTAGE THAT ARE FUTURE
BOSTON MARATHON BOMBERS BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT DOING ADEQUATE
VETTING.
>> OVER ON FOX, HUMAN MANURE
SPREADER TUCKER CARLSON HAS
FLOATED YET ANOTHER RACE BAITING
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF AFRICAN REFUGEES
ARE BEING SENT OVER TO THIS
COUNTRY IN ORDER TO CHANGE THE
OUTCOME OF ELECTIONS.
>> MANY WILL BE ALLOWED TO MOVE
AROUND THE UNITED STATES AND
STAY PERMANENTLY.
THEY DIDN'T SEEM TO ENCOUNTER
ANY PROBLEMS IN DOING THIS,
THANKS TO METICULOUS AND
THOUGHTFUL PLANNING.
OPERATION CHANGE AMERICA CAME
OFF PRECISELY ACCORDING TO PLAN.
IT WORKED FLAWLESSLY.
>> DID HE SAY OPERATION CHANGE
AMERICA FOREVER?
I THINK CHANGE IS ALREADY IN THE
AIR.
WE HAD AN INSURRECTION EIGHT
MONTHS AGO, AN INSURRECTION
THAT, LET'S FACE IT, HASN'T
REALLY ENDED.
IN PART BECAUSE YOU HAVE
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
USING THIS KIND OF RHETORIC.
>> IF OUR ELECTION SYSTEMS
CONTINUE TO BE RIGGED AND
CONTINUE TO BE STOLEN, THEN IT'S
GOING TO LEAD TO ONE PLACE AND
THAT'S BLOODSHED.
AND I WILL TELL YOU, AS MUCH AS
I AM WILLING TO DEPEND OUR
LIBERTY AT ALL COSTS, THERE'S
NOTHING THAT I DREAD DOING MORE
THAN HAVING TO PICK UP ARMS
AGAINST A FELLOW AMERICAN.
>> THE THREATENING LANGUAGE DOES
NOT END THERE.
IN RESPONSE TO THE JANUARY 6
COMMITTEE REQUESTING THE PHONE
RECORDS OF LAWMAKERS, SOME OF
WHOM MAY HAVE BEEN IN TOUCH WITH
THE INSURRECTIONISTS, HOUSE GOP
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY ISSUED A
STATEMENT WARNING THE TELEVISION
COMPANIES THAT COOPERATING WITH
THE COMMITTEE, QUOTE, A PUBLIC
MAJORITY WILL NOT FORGET.
THAT SOUNDED AN AWFUL LOT LIKE
WHAT CONGRESSWOMAN MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE HAD TO SAY.
>> THESE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES, THEY BETTER NOT PLAY
WITH THESE DEMOCRATS, BECAUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE COMING BACK INTO
THE MAJORITY IN 2022 AND WE WILL
TAKE THIS VERY SERIOUS.
THESE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES, IF THEY GO ALONG WITH
THIS, THEY WILL BE SHUT DOWN AND
THAT'S A PROMISE.
>> GOOD, I HOPE THEY'RE AFRAID
OF YOU.
THEY SHOULD BE.
THEY'RE VERY SHORT-SIGHTED.
THEY THINK DEMOCRATS WILL RULE
FOREVER BUT THEY SHOULD BE
AFRAID TO WEIGH IN TO POLICY
PARTISANS LIKE THIS.
>> CONGRESSMAN TAYLOR GREENE.
IF THEY GO ALONG WITH THIS, THEY
WILL BE SHUT DOWN.
CONGRESSMAN CAWTHORN.
IT'S GOING TO LEAD TO ONE PLACE
AND IT'S BLOODSHED.
OPERATION CHANGE AMERICA
FOREVER, INDEED.
TIMES ARE CHANGING DOWN IN
TEXAS.
THAT'S WHERE A BIZARRE NEW LAW
ALL BUT PROHIBITS ABORTION AND
CREATES A SO-CALLED BOUNTY
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS ORDINARY
PEOPLE TO SUE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS AND JUST ABOUT ANYONE
WHO HELPS A WOMAN GET THE
PROCEDURE.
>> WE RESPECT WHAT THE SUPREME
COURT JUST DID TO EMBOLDEN OTHER
STATES, AND FRANKLY OTHER
CONSERVATIVE CIRCUIT COURTS, TO
COMPLETELY IGNORE ROE V. WADE.
>> IF YOU'RE GETTING A
HANDMAID'S TALE VIBE FROM THIS,
YOU'RE NOT ALONE.
APOLOGIES IF YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
THE SHOW, BUT WHEN THEY SAY ONE
EYE ON TEXAS, DO THEY NOW MEAN
GREG ABBOTT?
WHO IS GOING TO BE DOING THE
SNITCHING?
WATCH OUT FOR AUNT LYDIA DOWN
THE STREET.
CERTAINLY IT WON'T BE THE SAME
PEOPLE SAYING, MY BODY, MY
CHOICE WHEN IT COMES TO MASK
MANDATES.
>> THERE IS A LOT OF OTHER GUYS
THAT CAN'T CONTROL THEMSELVES.
THAT'S WHERE THEY'RE NOT HERE
RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE NOTHING ELSE TO SAY.
DO WHAT'S RIGHT!
THERE IS A LOT OF BAD THINGS
COMING.
>> WE KNOW WHO YOU ARE!
WE KNOW WHO YOU ARE!
YOU CAN LEAVE FREELY, BUT WE
WILL FIND YOU AND WE KNOW WHO
YOU ARE!
WE KNOW WHO YOU ARE!
>> WHAT WILL WE TELL THE AFGHAN
REFUGEES WHO JUST FLED THOSE
SCHOOLS FOR GIRLS BACK IN THEIR
HOME COUNTRY?
I GUESS THE GIRLS HERE WILL HAVE
TO FILL THEM IN.
UNFORTUNATELY, WHAT WE WILL TELL
THEM IS THAT SOME MEMBERS OF THE
FAR RIGHT IN THIS COUNTRY HAVE
APPARENTLY DECIDED THEY WILL
RESORT TO INTIMIDATION, AND IN
SOME CASES, EVEN VIOLENCE TO GET
WHAT THEY WANT.
AND THEY COULD SWEEP INTO POWER
FASTER THAN THE EXPERTS THOUGHT
POSSIBLE.
SOUND FAMILIAR?
SORT OF LIKE AN AMERICAN
TALIBAN.
IT IS STARTING TO LOOK LIKE A
COMBINATION OF THEOCRACY AND
THUGOCRACY.
THE LEADERS OF THIS MAGA BAND
MOVEMENT, PEOPLE LIKE MARJORIE,
MADISON AND TUCKER, THEY'RE NOT
COUNTING ON A LACK OF PLANNING
ON YOUR PART.
THEY'RE COUNTING ON A LACK OF
COURAGE TO STAND UP FOR YOUR
RIGHTS IN THIS COUNTRY.
DOES THAT RING A BELL?
THE ANTI-IMMIGRATION,
ANTI-DEMOCRATIC, ANTI-WOMEN'S
RIGHTS 40s HAVE ALL SOUGHT THESE
KINDS OF CHANGES FOR YEARS, EVEN
DECADES, IN THIS COUNTRY.
THEIR OPERATION TO CHANGE
AMERICA FOREVER